silence absence voici nevers par un
après-midi de 2016
et pourtant à l'époque il y avait des
grands cafés il y avait des restaurants
il y avait plein de choses partout via
n'a plus rien du tout ça vient vraiment
être plus vieux même pu s'amuser à
nevers et dans bien d'autres communes de
taille moyenne des centres-villes quasi
désert la cause première
la france l'a découverte en 1969 ce sont
les centres commerciaux en périphérie
l'endroit idéal où l'on se perd se
trouvent et se garent à nouveau sans
compter que dans les années 60 le modèle
urbain par excellence ce sont les
quartiers pavillonnaires et les barres
d'immeubles en banlieue j'ai un
appartement que confortable
j'ai trois pièces cuisine salle de bain
j'ai deux enfants je sais quand même
moins d'habitants en ville la vie en
voiture et les zones commerciales
il n'en fallait pas plus pour freiner le
coeur des limes les petits commerçants
sont en quelque sorte est victime du
progrès
les centres commerciaux se multiplient
en périphérie dans les années 80 prenons
que dans le centre ville les commerces
souffrent aux sables d'olonne par
exemple en 1983 c'est toute une galerie
marchande qui met la clé sous la porte
on allait aux galeries d'une façon très
facile et l'a certainement que
nous allons avoir une un manque
d'éléments moteurs de centre ville
le centre-ville cumule les obstacles
pour le consommateur les prix y sont
plus élevés
le choix est limité et le stationnement
plus pénible je pense que le poids plus
grave est le problème du stationnement
nous sommes à compiègne dans une ville
historique à 2 avec des petites rues et
que le nombre de stationnements est tout
à fait limité le centre leclerc annonce
15000 places si le parking s'ils ouvrent
surface le nombre de fermetures
s'accentue dans les années 90 commerces
d'alimentation et de textile en première
ligne pour ceux qui restent ouverts
difficile de résister les commerçants
très souvent n'ont plus les moyens
financiers de réinvestir edda müller la
magasins tels que devrait le faire ou ou
tel qu'il y aurait deux souhaitable
qu'ils aient ensuite de le faire peu à
peu certains centres villes se sont
dégradées de plus en plus de locaux
commerciaux ne retrouve pas de repreneur
en 2012 7,2 pour cent des commerces
étaient inoccupés 9,5 pour cent en 2015
pour dépasser les 11 % en 2017
[Musique]